Uh, we got Yeah, we got a Muslim guest.
I think you're a Muslim. How you doing,
man?
>> Yeah. Hello. How are you, man?
>> Pretty good. Pretty good. What's on your
mind?
>> You wouldn't mind if I uh ask the
question?
>> I can't hear you if you go off the app.
What' you say?
>> No, I wasn't off the app. My bad. Wait.
But would you mind if I asked the
question?
>> Go ahead.
>> It's kind of Yeah. So, I was with my
friend yesterday and he said something
about uh you said you made like a whole
live stream saying Muhammad affirmed the
crucifixion.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Could I see like the proof of
that?
>> You want to see the Yeah. No problem.
>> Is your friend a Christian or a Muslim?
>> No, he's a Muslim.
>> Okay. So, what did he think about the
the hadith?
>> No, I'm not sure. He just told me that
what's it called?
>> Muhammad that you made a live stream
saying Muhammad affirmed it.
>> I have like only like seven minutes or
like six.
>> I'll be as I'll be as quick as I can,
bro.
>> Thank you. And my computer shut off. So,
I have my iPad. I have like an iPad. My
brother's right next to me. Okay.
>> So, if you just give me like a source,
I'll I'll try to go on to it.
>> Yeah. I got you. I got you. I got you.
So, um, we're going to pull up Sahib
Bukari 692. Now, I'm going to show it on
the screen for you, too.
>> It's Sai Bukari, uh, 6929.
And then, um, right beside it, I'm going
to put Luke chapter 23. Okay. To show
you what it's what it's referring to.
>> All right. So, let me just do this.
All right. Let me open.
>> Wait, Luke. Uh, that was Jesus his last
words on the cross. No,
>> not his last words, but one of one of
one of his words.
>> It's like when he Yeah. When he was like
hanged and like
>> Yeah. When he was on the cross. Yep.
>> Luke 23 verse 32.
Okay. All right. Okay. Let me open up my
camera for you.
>> Hey, Logic. I'mma drop real quick. I'll
be back in about
>> Yeah. Yeah. Whatever. Whatever.
>> I'll be right back, bro.
>> I don't even want you here anyway. It's
wild. Go ahead. Do Do your thing, man.
No, it's cool. No. Oh,
>> I'm No, bro. I'm sorry, man. Sorry, man.
I'll be right back, bro.
>> Okay. So, so Sai Bukari 6929.
>> Yeah,
>> it say you put it up. All right, cool.
Narrated Abdullah as if I am looking at
the prophet while he was speaking about
one of the prophets whose people have
beaten and wounded him. And he was
wiping the blood off his face and
saying, "Oh Lord, forgive my people as
they do not know." Right? And then The
only place that we find these words in
history are right here in Luke 22 where
it says two others who were criminals
were led away to be put to death with
him. And when they came to the place
that is called the skull, they crucified
him. There they crucified him. And uh
the criminals, one on his right and one
on his left and Jesus said, "Father,
forgive them for they know not what they
do." And they cast lots to divide his
garments. So, uh, I'm assuming that
you're saying that since there's a
correlation between what they're saying,
then it has to be Jesus.
>> Yes.
>> So, I have a question. So, basically,
there's an issue with what you're saying
with what I'm observing, if you don't
mind me saying. So, the problem is Luke
23:30 is when Jesus is on a Roman style
crucifixion, meaning his uh what's it
called? His wrist is nailed to a tree.
The problem is in the hadith, it's
saying, "And he was wiping the blood off
his face." So if you're going to quote
the last words of Jesus, you have to
realize that it has to be in the exact
moment the hadith is talking about.
Meaning that Jesus has to be saying this
and wiping the blood off his face. So I
want to know how he wiped off his face
the blood when he's stuck on a Roman
style crucifixion when his uh what's it
called? His wrists are nailed. Hello.
Did you hear me?
>> My hands are widespread right now. Like
I'm on a cross.
>> Yeah.
>> And I'm wiping my face like on a
shoulder.
>> One sec. Let me pull it up. So how do
you wipe the blood off your face like
that? I'm doing it. If I have blood on
my face right now, I'll be there'll be
blood on my shoulder because I'm wiping
my face with my shoulder right now.
>> Okay. So, I know the argument. So,
that's why I was going to move on to the
second point. The problem is if our
earliest tiers have said that it's about
another prophet, what would you say?
>> I would ask them for the evidence of
that. Where what evidence do they have
that there's another prophet that went
through this and that actually said
these words and where do we find this in
history? Cuz this is the only place we
find this.
>> So, the thing is, you know, prophet.
>> Yes. What what what do they have to
suggest that Noah was beaten by his
people and said these words? Cuz them
claiming this doesn't mean anything.
What evidence do they have? Do they have
a text in history that that corroborates
that?
>> No. Look, Mil is known for generally
saying like forgive my people and stuff
like that after years of treatment cuz
we believed he lived for over like 900
years. And when he would say that,
right?
>> No.
>> Whenever he No. Yeah. Whenever he would
get beat would always ask for
forgiveness for his people.
>> Where do you where where is where you
get this from?
No, no, no. The question is where do
they get this from?
>> Quran because it's not in the Quran.
>> No, it's in the Quran.
>> Okay. So, show me in the Quran where
Noah said, "Oh, uh Lord, forgive my
people as they do not know."
>> Oh, yeah. Sure. No, I'm not saying.
Look, the thing is there's not going to
be a direct quotation that has the exact
same uh what's it called? It's not going
to have the the exact same uh the words
that Jesus said.
>> It's not going to have none of the words
he said.
>> Huh? It's not going to have any other
words,
>> but the general meaning is going to be
the exact same. Meaning that he wants
his people to be forgiven even though
they're sinning constantly. And he was
by his people.
>> Where where in the Quran does it show
that he's being beaten up by his people
and as a resort is saying, "Lord,
forgive them for they do not know what
they're going."
>> He was beaten. He was beaten up by his
people, but he never said, "Lord,
forgive."
>> Show me the evidence.
>> Okay, guys. Wait. I need to charge my
iPad. It's on. It's
>> okay.
>> I'm going just charge it.
>> My bad.
Nope. Take your time, man. Take your
time.
[Music]
>> Dude, if I have my computer, it'll be
easier. So, I'm sorry for making the
conversation long. How often are you
live? Because I might have to go soon.
So, I would try to do
>> I'll be I'll be live for a while. I'll
be live uh for like another hour and
some change.
>> Okay.
>> Yep. So, you can come back uh whenever
you're ready, bro.
>> No, I can talk for like 7 minutes. Just
give me like a link.
>> Okay. Just give me a sec.
>> I'm Can I turn my camera? Wait.
>> All right, I got you.
>> So here. So the thing is in the hadith
just to clarify it, it doesn't have to
be word for word. We just have to know
the general meaning has to be the same.
So
>> what what has to be is the same
situation and the quote from the hadith
that it's talking about.
>> The the hadith and the quote isn't the
exact same thing as the the Bible quote.
It's just
>> I didn't say it's the exact same thing.
It's a paraphrase of what he says.
>> Okay.
>> Right. So not notice notice notice what
we're working with. We're working with
when it comes to Jesus, we have the
literal situation where he's beaten by
his own people. Then he's put on a cross
and then he says the words, "Father,
forgive them for they know not what they
do." Right? So this hadith is
referencing an event, one of the
prophets, and the only person that we
have documented of this situation and
saying these words is Jesus. So if you
have something of documentation with
Noah, I'm willing to look take a look at
it, bro. So
>> you want the general meaning to be the
same?
>> I want the situation and the quote.
>> Okay, just let me find it.
>> All right, my camera.
>> Say that again.
>> Is my camera on?
>> Your camera's not on. You probably You
got to push the camera button and then
push save.
>> Oh, wait. I'm going switch. Save.
>> There you go.
>> This is what I got.
>> All right. What verse is this?
>> It's just
verse 711. Just go from 711. Can we just
read it together then?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Go ahead.
>> So it starts indeed we said no to his
people saying to him warn your people
before a painful punishment comes to
them. Then the second verse Noah
proclaimed oh my people I'm truly sent
to you with a clear warning. Worship
Allah alone. Fear him and obey me. He
will forgive your sins and delay your
end until the appointed time. Indeed
when time said by Allah comes, it cannot
be delayed. If only you knew. He cried,
"My Lord, I have surely called my people
day and night. But my calls only made
them run farther away. And whenever I
invite them to be forgiven by you, they
press their fingers into their ears,
cover themselves with their clothes,
persist in denial, and act very
arrogantly. Then I certainly call them
openly, and then I surely preach them
publicly and privately, saying, "Seek
your Lord's forgiveness, for he is truly
most forgiving. He will shower you with
abundant rain, supplied with wealth and
children, and give you guidance as well
as your What is the matter with you that
you were not in the ar of the majesty of
Allah when he truly created you in
stages of development?" Let's going to
keep on creation then. Wait, but you can
see that the situation was near the
same. The situation is nowhere near the
same.
>> Yeah, it is.
>> Where?
>> Come on, brother.
>> Dude, and whenever I invite Wait, one
sec.
>> He cried, "My Lord, I've surely called
my people day and night, but my calls
only made them run farther away. And
whenever I invite them to be forgiven by
you, they press their fingers into their
ears, cover themselves with their
clothes, persistent denial, and act very
arrogantly. Then I certainly call them
openly. Then I surely preach them
private uh privately and publicly and
privately, saying, "Seek your Lord's
forgiveness, for he is truly most
forgiving." So where is where is Noah
beaten?
>> They acted arrogant against him.
>> Yeah, but where is where do they beat
him?
>> I'll bring that up in the hadith
probably a sec.
>> So we in the Quran, we don't see Noah
being beaten. Nor do we see him saying
Lord forgive them cuz they know not.
They don't know what they're doing.
>> We don't see the situation uh what's it
called? Uh near the same. And then if I
bring
>> It's nowhere near the same, bro.
>> Okay. Okay. What I'm asking is if I
bring you evidence from the hadith of
the Quran that he was beaten, would the
situation be near the same? No, it
wouldn't because he still's not is not
making the statement for the Lord to
forgive them for they because they don't
know.
>> He asked them to be No, he said, "My
Lord, whenever I look Wait, uh he said,
"My Lord, I've surely called my people
day and night, but my calls only made
them run farther away." So, he's asking
him what he should do in this situation.
>> Yeah. Does is that him asking that Lord
forgive my people for they don't know
what they're doing?
>> The hadith didn't exactly say that.
>> The hadith does. It says, "Oh Lord,
forgive my people as they do not know."
>> Yeah. It's not word for word. It's just
the general meaning.
>> That's not even That's not even
paraphrase, bro. That's not even a
general meaning. It has nothing to Okay,
let let me ask you this. Does Abraham
ask for Allah to forgive the people?
>> Huh?
>> Does he ask for Allah to forgive the
people?
>> I'm not sure. I'm not sure.
>> In the verses that we read, did he ask
them? Did he ask Allah to forgive them?
>> Who? Abraham.
>> Noah.
>> Wait, I'm pulling I'm trying to pull
something.
>> In the verses that we just read,
brother, did Abra did Noah ask if I said
Abraham, I made a mistake. Did Noah ask
um
you know Allah to forgive the people
that were acting arrogantly?
>> I don't not exactly. No
>> no he didn't.
>> So do you see the the difference here is
that with
>> for the people saying you're ch it's not
judgy.
>> Yeah. Forget guys be be nice to him man.
He's uh you know he's engaging logically
and you know so be cool.
>> Um so look look at the difference that
that we have here. I have Jesus where
who I have a hold on just let me say
this. I have a documented
reference
of the prophet that was going through
this and said these words and the hadith
points to that. And so what you're
bringing me with Noah is nowhere close
to what I see with Jesus.
>> You get what I'm saying? Like it doesn't
touch the situation.
>> So if I show you it from you know whoab
is, right? I need I would I yeah I know
who he is. I would need him to I would
need to know where he's getting this
from.
>> What if it's like the chain of
transmissions to the prophet?
>> Well, I would need what? Look, this is
what I'm saying. I would need Omar.
>> Well, they learned they learned the
story. If they learn the Quran from the
prophet, whatever they say would be from
the prophet in terms of the
>> I disagree because there's some things
that Umar like for example some
abrogations that Umar came up with that
Muhammad didn't.
>> Arma came up with abrogations.
>> Yeah. I Yeah. If I um if I remember
correctly, the verse of uh I think it
was Muta, I think it was. I think Muta I
think I think Umar was the last one to
like absolutely abrogate it if I'm not
mistaken. Um
>> okay. Well, you know, you know what?
This what we'll do because I I don't
want to say anything and not back it up.
So, I for the next stream, I'll bring
I'll bring this up. Thank you, Study. I
knew I wasn't tripping, but uh I'll get
my information together and I'll
showcase it on the next on the next I'm
live again on uh I'll probably be live
again tomorrow. So,
>> what time what time will it be live?
>> Same same time.
>> Okay. So, around What time did you
start?
>> I I started this stream two hours ago.
>> Okay. I'll try to join around that. Can
I just show you what the son of
reported in his one of his that it was
about Noah?
>> I um brother I I understand that there
are some taps that say it's about Noah.
That's not my concern.
>> The thing is the taps come from like the
earliest people of the
>> No, they don't. Where is it? Where where
is Umar getting this from?
>> Dude is literally the earliest basically
he's the son of
>> I have no problem with that. My question
is where is he getting it from? He gets
it from who gets it from.
>> Where does he how do you know that he's
getting that from Muhammad? Where does
Muhammad say that this is about Noah?
>> That boy had a haram ringtone. Did y'all
hear that? There was just something in
me that automatically just start nodding
like this. When you when you got me just
automatically by in by instinct doing
this, you know your phone haram. Yo,
that ringtone haram. You're not supposed
to have that. You know you're not
supposed to have that. Come on, man. You
ain't supposed to have no music in
Islam. Can't be having a host. You can't
Hey, that was that was a smooth little
beat. You can't have that in Islam. That
was That was a smooth little beat right
there. But I lost him though. I don't
know. Oh, there he is.
>> No, dude. Dude, it said watch next live
or something. And I had like a bunch of
music.
>> Oh,
>> but uh Yeah, I didn't actually leave on
purpose.
>> No, I know. I know. I know. That was an
accident. I know.
>> It's It's Tik Tok. It's Tik Tok. Yeah.
>> But so if I show you that the earliest
uh person that did a on it was the son
of and he said that it was about. So
what would he say about that?
>> What I would say is is that does nothing
for me because I don't know where the
son of Umar is getting that from. What
documentation does he have? Do we have
any historical scripture that
demonstrates that Noah historically was
beaten by his people and asked the Lord
to forgive his people cuz they don't
know what they're doing? Do we does do
we have documentation of that? Cuz we
have documentation for Jesus. We don't
have documentation for nobody else. So I
me just trusting the son of Umar is it
won't it does nothing for me.
>> Yeah, I see where that comes from. So if
I like Yeah. Hello.
>> Yeah.
>> If I could bring it to you from the
hadith, right? or like the Quran, would
you accept it?
>> I would accept if you have because this
is talking about a, you know, document,
a story, an event that happens in Noah's
time.
>> If there's documentation that this
actually happened with Noah, this has
to, this is pre-Coran, bro, pre-Islam.
So, this if this is like in the Torah,
if this is like, you know, in the actual
scriptures that demonstrate, oh yeah,
this happened to Noah,
>> documentation of it, I have to take it.
But if not, everything else is is fluff.
The the person that we have, notice the
person that we have that matches this
directly that we have historical
documentation of is Jesus. That's the
only one.
>> Then can I bring it to you? Can I come
tomorrow in your life?
>> Yep. Come tomorrow. Come tomorrow. Come
anytime you want, man. Cuz I you you
cool. So come come anytime, bro.
>> If I come If you're live for like one
more hour, I probably could be able to
film.
>> Okay.
>> I'll see you
>> for sure. Sounds good, bro.
>> I'll see you, buddy. Thank you.
>> All right. Take care.